this man's been on before i think we met
on a flight to las vegas nevada
many many years ago and um
i think he was he was he was on the show
las vegas at the time
and his new show jupiter's legacy can be
seen it's a new
netflix netflix original series
available today
on netflix starring josh jamel how are
you josh
i'm doing all right rich i just want to
know how do i follow that last segment
by being yourself josh by being your
good old-fashioned self
is that that's my memory that we met on
a plane right
were you flying to vegas to work on the
show las vegas and we were i was flying
out there for who knows what i don't
know
i don't remember that being the first
time i i just remember
uh there was like sunday like parties
that
at your place was somebody's place
and i think at the time you just had one
child it was a while ago now right
but i don't remember it being a fight it
was a flight two vegas or from vegas
because those are two very different
mindsets
[Laughter]
i think it was uh one of the other but i
think you were again
shooting your the the show uh las vegas
on nbc
that's how long ago it was um i guess
let me
let me just ask you that let me start
there you got a good james khan story
that you can tell on the air oh i got a
million of them what do you got
i learned so much from that dude so much
about what to do
and also what not to do uh and here's
the first one to tell you don't do this
kid
trust me i made this mistake many times
uh but you know jimmy was
j i still keep in touch with him he's he
was a mentor to me for five years and he
would i mean that guy would
he would he would he it was always i
always knew when i wasn't
you know performing at the level he
expected huh
because i'd get this little look so i'm
gonna be like josh come over here for a
second
like oh here we go
[Laughter]
so he took me back behind the i think
you corner be pushing a little bit too
hard you need to just let it happen
all this just just let it be just let
the scene come to you
and he would give me like really sound
advice that i actually i actually used
even
today um you know he's he's
jimmy come on he's james sonny corleone
i mean and so much more i mean my god
um you know that's uh james khan josh
dumel here on the rich eisen show
well the funny thing is that you know
nowadays people don't even know him for
something corleone every kid thinks of
him as
your buddy's dad and elf oh it's
unbelievable that drove him crazy by the
way
he didn't have no idea what i did
dude i'm telling you uh the other day i
told this story on the show
my kids i as you point out i have more
than one now i got three
so just getting them to all agree on
watching something is so insane so they
finally agree to watch a movie the war
with
grandpa starred de niro and it struck me
and susie the two of us looked at each
other in the middle saying this is the
first robert de niro movie my kids are
seeing
yeah and like i just had to pause the
movie i'm like you see grandpa right
there
you we're gonna all watch some movies
eventually not now
not for a while we're gonna watch a taxi
driver
in about about 15 years he's going to
have this mohawk and let me tell you
it was a little sideways um but you know
it's
it you know it's just amazing how these
things were i had it we had to tell them
like
that's literally one of the greatest
living american actors of all time
you know yeah so that's so funny that
that kind of upset
james khan is like i'm not i'm not
buddy's dad a little bit more
a little bit more than that um what do
you think of the vikings um
draft i don't know how familiar you are
with it they drafted kellenbond the
when they passed on uh mack jones
because i felt like you know if he's
good enough
for the patriots he's got to be good
enough for the vikings
um and i guess i guess time will tell
you know uh i think cousins is a
perfectly possible quarterback i just
don't see us winning a super bowl with
him and i feel like we need
that young quarterback that we can
develop into
you know hopefully a championship
winning quarterback and i thought that
might be
mac jones maybe they know i'm sure they
know more than i do
uh spielman's done a good job in the
draft through the years but you know
what i saw this kellen mon
play at texas a m and this guy was a
stud
i think he was the first quarterback to
come in after manziel right
i think he played four years there he
did play he played he is a stud
there's no doubt about it he he really
is and he's got
he's got an upside there's no question
it he could really develop into a
nice quarterback but you know uh time
will tell
i hope i'm wrong oh i really do hope i'm
wrong because there's nothing i want
more than a
super bowl ring well timing's everything
in life i guess
in a way is it if i'm not mistaken did
you play quarterback
when you were um in high school i did
and i'm still available you know well i
mean your timing
your timing was off i mean you know if
only you came out in the last few years
uh you know from from north dakota state
you know look
look at whence and now trey lance your
your timing was off
josh your timing's way off if you think
about there were
there's the last four quarterbacks to
play nbfc have all gone pro there's
jensen
brock jensen was his name great i think
he might even be in a league somewhere
still
then there was uh carson
yeah after carson was eastern stick
who's i believe still with the chargers
and then and now it's uh trey atlanta so
they they're
putting out like nfl quarterbacks on
thursday
i guess crazy are you sure brock jensen
wasn't part of
ron burgundy's news team because that's
what it sounds like to me
look it up man i don't think he's ever
played but i know that he was a second
or third trainer
maybe not last year but he was
definitely drafted and played several
leagues yeah man your timing's off you
could have been the first you could have
been the george washington of this
johnson ndsu
ndsu would even give me a sniff really
no i'd play for the beavers baby
so my state university beavers so what
i wasn't quite good enough to play with
bison so who did monet state beat
i mean who did you beat who did you take
down back in the day you took down
uh we had a good team my
freshman sophomore the junior year
right fell off a little bit my senior
year but uh
we went to like the ncaa nai final four
my sophomore year
all right i had nothing to do with it i
was the backup quarterback
you're the clipboard
state miners of the beavers is that what
that was okay you're the number two
quarterback there
uh josh dumel here on the rich
eisenshire all right brother tell me
about uh
jupiter's legacy available today on
netflix you leslie bibb ben daniels
uh you are playing uh sheldon sampson
aka the utopian
this is you uh entering uh a a fun
and also you know serious look at uh
at some superhero action right here you
know i never
i never thought i was i thought this
[ __ ] had failed for me i didn't think i
was
you know if i was going to play a
superhero i thought it would have been
like 15 years ago right and i wasn't
even really looking to do it
um but this script came along it was
really really good it wasn't even so
much about the superhero stuff but it
was like a
like this badass like family
drama about this dysfunctional uh family
of superheroes
and and it spans like 90 years there's a
whole origin story that
starts in the 30s right after the market
crash
my character goes in this crazy sort of
mental breakdown
breezy's visions which leads them up to
this island which also ultimately gets
them these powers but
then we flash back to present day and
we've had these powers over 90 years and
you get to kind of see the repercussions
of that and what
you know how that wears on you and the
pressures and the responsibilities and
you know the the
you know the family sort of uh
resentment that it builds with
your kids and having not been there for
you know so anybody with
family or kids especially kids 15 to 20
will
really get it because you know this guy
can you know fly around the world in
12 seconds and shoot laser beams out of
his eyeballs but
he's powerless when it comes to
communicating with his daughter but also
i'll tell you this josh i mean you um
being uh
as you said you thought that 15 years
ago would be the time for you to to do
this sort of thing when you're
i guess doing your highly successful
transformers run
i mean that's that's all you in the suit
though right i mean that's
that's that there's no there's no
enhancement right i mean that's all
that's all me rich okay call me i just
want to make sure
i mean there's there's no like you know
um
suit underneath the suit that's that's
that's josh dumel
right i wish i could say that were true
man it was so it was so
cool to put that thing on and be like oh
my god i'm so yoked
look at me and then i'll take it off and
there's nothing more masculine than
taking that muscle suit off and
oh yeah that's what i actually like
but it was fun because i got to put on
this you know this prosthetic
you know aging things and they'd age my
face up and i just big long
you know right mop up hair with this big
i looked like moses or zeus or yeah like
sexy santa claus or something
right but it was uh and it was it was a
lot of fun because i immediately felt
like i was this old dude who's been too
many battles and
you know it's kind of at the tail end of
his career as a superhero
that beard is all real though right
that's your beard did you grow up i wish
come on dude that thing was a pain in
the butt to put on everybody no
kidding all right i thought that was
that's impressive the whole thing
um yeah all right josh dumel er uh my
best to you and
and everyone else um i hope to see you i
hope to see you in person next time
all this business on the phone i'd love
to do it i wish i could you can see me
now rich i'm in like a
mocap suit okay you know where they put
like all the
little reflector balls and stuff on i
got a bunch of dots all over my face
are you really what what video game are
you doing what are you doing well
i can't they would kill me if i said but
it's a
sort of um it's the same company that i
did the call of duty with a few years
ago
okay so the call of duty game but it's a
pretty badass look at you you are
you are that's next level promotion like
let everyone i'm letting everyone know
on jupiter's legacy and netflix that
you're you're multitasking
you're telling the crew hey man i know i
got the dots and everything on but i
gotta call in the rich eisen show to
when i had to come out to promote to you
like oh big timer here has got to go out
and talk to rich eisen
that's right tell them tell them i said
hello um
and i i appreciate you doing your thing
hey why don't you
pop a photograph of yourself right now
on twitter and
instagram and we'll we'll share it with
our viewers here right now rich not a
boy
well done josh dumas thank you buddy
talk to you soon same to you you be well
that's josh dumail everybody check out
jupiter's legacy on netflix very
handsome man
very hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here